[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mardi 20 décembre voici le programme
de ce 7 8 nous commencerons cette
émission avec les informations du jour
nous parlerons de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
qui va éteindre ses lumières de Noël
pendant une heure demain en solidarité
avec l'Ukraine nous parlerons également
de la nouvelle salle d'escalade qui
vient de s'ouvrir à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et d'une
conférence sur les arnaques en ligne qui
sont organisés à La Verrière au
programme également une belle initiative
ce dimanche 18 décembre l'association
pharmaceutoyens et son président
fondateur Mustapha Larbaoui ont emmené
en sortie 19 enfants de l'équipe de
football de Guyancourt et 6 enfants de
Trappes Mustapha Larbaoui sera notre
invité dans ce 7 8 enfin nous partirons
du côté de Montigny-le-Bretonneux Didier
Chambon a mis en place un projet de
compost collectif dans sa résidence en
2019 un intérêt environnemental pour les
habitants permettant également de créer
du lien social reportage à suivre
et le point tout de suite sur
l'actualité du jour dans les Yvelines
avec notre journaliste Céline Charles
[Musique]
Saint-Germain-en-Laye dans le noir en
solidarité pour l'Ukraine la ville
étendra ses lumières de Noël pendant une
heure sur les places et dans les rues
mercredi 21 décembre à 20h heure locale
l'action du rat une heure c'est une
initiative du parlement
ukrainien pour soutenir le pays et elle
concerne les municipalités qui acceptent
de participer les habitants sont
encouragés à faire de même si vous
habitez Sartrouville peut-être que vous
aurez la chance d'apercevoir le Père
Noël près de chez vous avec sa barbe et
son costume rouge caractéristique Rémi
foret un agent éboueur chauffeur de la
mairie de Sartrouville a décidé de faire
ses tournées de collecte de déchets
déguisés en Père Noël il faudra
cependant se lever tôt pour l'apercevoir
Rémy commence à 6h il passe notamment
par les quartiers du vieux pays et de
Tobrouk apprendre à se prémunir contre
les escroqueries en ligne savoir les
repérer c'est ce que propose la ville de
La Verrière à ses habitants lors d'un
temps digital il faudra se rendre demain
mercredi 21 décembre de 14h à 16h à
l'espace Jacques nickel pour assister à
la conférence menée par un conseiller
numérique plus d'informations au numéro
qui s'affichent en bas de l'écran si
vous êtes d'une nouvelle salle a ouvert
au centre commercial Skywest à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux à pic contient
100 voix et 32 murs d'escalade de 8
mètres de haut la salle est ouverte à
toute la famille des 4 ans plusieurs
niveaux de difficultés sont proposés
dont des murs de première grimpe pour
les débutants parcours d'accrobranche
toboggan ou bambou pour se jeter dans le
vide sont également présents sur place
compter 15 euros de l'heure pour
l'entrée vous connaissiez Primark les
clés sous bois vous présente maintenant
Nomi son homologue français le magasin
ouvert ses portes à Alpha Park et
propose des articles à prix très
abordables installé sur 6500 m², vous
pourrez retrouver des vêtements pour
femmes hommes et enfants des accessoires
de mode et de la maroquinerie c'est le
deuxième magasin de cette enseigne sur
le territoire yvelinois après auberge en
ville enfin dans le cadre du plan de
sobriété énergétique de 50 ans en
Yvelines la piscine Salvador Allende
située aux Clayes-sous-Bois et
contraintes de fermer pour les vacances
elle rouvrira le 2 janvier 2023
et pour les civils lois qui ont un
billet de train pour les fêtes de Noël
une grève et programmée à la SNCF ce
vendredi 23 décembre en raison une grève
des agents du service commercial des
trains en moyenne intrins sur trois sera
supprimé les prévisions pour le samedi
24 et dimanche 25 décembre ne sont pas
encore connues le trafic devait être
perturbé jusqu'à lundi pour savoir si
votre train est supprimé ou non
rendez-vous sur le site de la SNCF si
vous aussi vous voyez une information ou
une image qui vous a marqué près de chez
vous dans les Yvelines n'hésitez pas à
nous les partager sur Twitter et le
hashtag 7 8 news le hashtag de tv78
[Musique]
on va maintenant parler d'une belle
initiative ce dimanche
fondateurs
de l'équipe de football de Guyancourt et
6 enfants de Trappes au programme
découverte de Verdun et de ses musées le
lendemain a des enfants pu visiter à
l'Assemblée nationale toujours avec
Pharma citoyen nous avons avec nous sur
ce plateau le président fondateur
Mustapha Larbaoui bonsoir bonsoir alors
comment se sont passés ces deux jours
bah écoutez elle se passe toutes
toujours très bien
pour la raison pour la bonne raison que
les enfants sont tellement preneurs de
ce genre de de voyage d'abord parce que
ça les sort ils ont envie de sortir
d'une part donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle on fait des sorties et des
visites de musées relativement loinains
pour aller en province pour aller
voyager d'une part et d'autre part voilà
ils absorbent tout ce qu'ils voient ils
sont attentifs à tout ils sont curieux
de tout bref faut pas en être comment
dire faut pas être étonné ses propres
des enfants et c'est pour ça que ça fait
plaisir à voir parce qu'en réalité ils
sont ainsi ils ont envie d'apprendre
pour comprendre un beau souvenir
également dans les minibus je crois
qu'il y avait 4 minibus vous avez écouté
à la radio cette finale de la Coupe du
monde entre la France et l'Argentine
alors j'avais une contrainte horaire
effectivement c'était de reprendre le
minibus à 16h et donc on a vécu ce temps
fort que des millions ont vécu à la à la
télé mais gravité ça s'écoute aussi un
match de foot et donc pour l'imaginaire
en même temps on la radio à cette vertu
donc oui nous avons vécu les moments de
difficiles pour tout début de match les
moments de doute jusqu'à la fin et puis
et puis la liesse bien évidemment des
enfants lorsqu'ils ont vu que la
remontada fonctionnait et qui avait
encore moyen de passer jusqu'à la
déception finale mais tout ça tout ça à
la radio effectivement dans les minibus
mais au-delà d'un match comme celui-ci
les ambiances dans les minibus sont
toujours sont toujours très agréables
alors ça peut être des fois on fait
classe on révise certaines choses ou
alors il y a des chansons bref il se
passe sur quelque chose et c'est
toujours très très agréable alors pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas encore
pharmacitoyens est-ce qu'on pourrait
présenter cette association qui a été
créée en 2007 alors créé en 2007
pharmacie citoyen c'est simple je suis
pharmacien j'ai toujours pensé que
chacun d'entre nous était un citoyen
donc c'était facile de faire ce jeu de
mots de pharmacies citoyen en 2007 et
voilà ça évolué doucement on a fait il y
a beaucoup d'actions qui sont menées par
exemple pour le pour du don de matériel
médical ou d'autres actions dont je ne
parlerai pas pour pas être trop long
mais ce que je garde surtout
j'ai envie de dire sur de plus de plus
important c'est le fait de suivre
des CM2 sur leur cours d'histoire donc
en fait on plaque nos initiatives notre
initiative pardon et nos sorties sur le
programme histoire des CM2 voilà il y a
trois phases à peu près ce sont les
guerres jusqu'à la paix Première et
Seconde Guerre mondiale on a
l'industrialisation et puis tout ce qui
tourne autour de la République et de ses
symboles donc pharmacie citoyen c'est 10
visites par an donc vous en avez citer
deux tout à l'heure Verdun et Assemblée
nationale mais en réalité c'est 10
sorties par an dans le programme
puisqu'on fait également Arromanches
pour la seconde guerre mondiale
Bruxelles pour la construction de la
paix on va également à Nantes parce
qu'il y a toute une histoire du
rattachement de la Bretagne à la France
et puis la traite négrière et enfin
le dernier voyage imméphane non c'est
Léva hard les Verdes qui est un centre
minier ça ce sont pour les voyages en
province
nous faisons également 5 visites
parisiennes donc le Sénat l'Assemblée
nationale
le musée de l'immigration le musée de la
Shoah et puis il y a l'écocitoyenneté
qui se fait sur la scène et sur l'Oise
où on explique un peu comment ça se
passe et on va même à la pêche mais
surtout à la pêche aux bouteilles en
plastique donc c'est 10 sorties par an
et par partenaire c'est à dire que nous
avons nos actions avec des partenaires
et le choix
le choix était fait
faut pas m'en vouloir d'être aller voir
des partenaires que je connaissais
puisque
président de foot pendant 14 ans à
Trappes et donc du coup tout ça était
déjà fait attrape donc l'idée m'est
venue de d'aller voir d'autres présentes
comme de foot puisqu'ils ont par
définition un grand nombre d'enfants de
10 ans donc en CM2 et donc les
partenariats se sont fait très
naturellement avec des présidents de
clubs de foot donc je veux remercier ici
présente Guyancourt par exemple 8 avec
son équipe qui font un très très gros
travail le groupe de le club de plaisir
excellent travail également le groupe de
Élancourt mais il y a également
Coignières facilement ouais très
facilement certes ils me connaissait de
l'époque de ma présidence attrape et du
sujet que je traite aujourd'hui donc il
savait ensuite on explique et on fait
des réunions donc réunions présidente
réunion du conseil d'administration du
club et enfin on essaie d'avoir les
parents pour que les parents soient
impliqués et je tiens à dire que si
c'est une initiative de pharmacie
citoyen le but ultime c'est que chaque
club s'accapare du projet et que ça
devienne un projet club je suis toujours
pensé que le sport c'était important
donc le foot mais ça pourrait être tout
autre tout autre club sportif ou même
sur d'autres notions
mais je pense qu'on peut faire plus
lorsqu'on a un groupe d'enfants à gérer
sur le plan éducatif donc le foot et la
pratique d'abord et ce plus que des
présidents acceptent de faire et
ce que je souhaite c'est qu'il est plus
en plus de président qui adhère à ce
projet puisqu'on vise les 12 communes de
la l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
et à Trappes tout particulièrement pour
être pour y avoir passé quand même une
vingtaine d'années j'ai ouvert ce
programme à toutes les associations de
la ville pour essayer de constituer un
groupe cette fois-ci soit d'un club qui
voudrait adhérer soit de plusieurs
associations et là je travaille l'OMS
qui est le fils municipal des sports qui
est en contact avec les associations
sportives de trappes et nous avions hier
6 enfants de Trappes qui est une
mobilisation de maman qui sont venus me
voir et qui m'ont dit que c'était super
et j'en profite pour terminer pour
remercier les instituteurs on disait les
maîtresses les maîtres les institutrices
de CM2 qui font un boulot remarquable
voilà c'est juste un clin d'œil en leur
direction parce que je sais leur travail
comment il peut être à la fois
passionnant difficile mais il faut un
travail admirable et nous on ne fait que
illustrer ce programme histoire en
faisant des voyages dernière question en
30 secondes quel est votre meilleur
souvenir depuis 2007 avec pharmacie
citoyen si vous deviez en retenir qu'un
très sincèrement je peux pas répondre à
cette question parce qu'ils sont tous
ça se passe tout le temps de la même
façon on voit bien que les enfants ont
envie d'apprendre aiment apprendre ont
envie de comprendre et s'amusent à la
fois dans le minibus et en voyage donc
j'en ai pas un en particulier ils sont
tous pareils et en fait je suis jamais
étonné parce que c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne pour eux et c'est un vrai
vrai plaisir merci à vous à Mustapha
lahbaoui je le rappelle vous êtes
président fondateur de pharmacie
citoyens il nous a associé en 2007
on va maintenant prendre la direction de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux Didier Chambon a
mis en place un projet de compost
collectif dans sa résidence en 2019 ce
guide composteur alimentaire accompagne
au total une quarantaine de familles
dans cette gestion des bio des chiens
d'un terrain environnemental pour les
habitants permettant également de créer
du lien social à un reportage de Julien
Leroy
fédérer autour de la réduction des
déchets une priorité pour Didier Chambon
c'est inimy montant de 53 ans a monté en
2019 ce compost collectif dans sa
copropriété il a suivi cette année une
formation pour devenir guide composteur
l'objectif accompagner les familles dans
une bonne gestion des biodéchets tout
est parti d'un petit groupe de voisins
qui partageaient les un petit peu les
mêmes valeurs environnementales comme
ici on a une copro ça doit passer par un
vote en assemblée générale et donc nous
à notre grande surprise ça a été voté à
l'unanimité on faisait des tri déjà
mais on à la fin les déchets qui étaient
pas recyclables étaient mélangées avec
les déchets qui pouvaient justement fait
partie de compost pour notre famille
c'était intéressant pour ça de montrer
les enfants qui la nature elle est
cyclique sur les 110 familles de la
résidence une quarantaine participent au
compost ce procédé de dég des biodéchets
permet d'éviter environ 85 kg de déchets
par habitant et par an un véritable
intérêt écologique mais aussi un vecteur
de lien social ça nous a permis de
rencontrer des gens un petit peu
introverti des gens qui se sont tes
proches de la nature et besoin de
pouvoir participer à ce genre de projet
et avec qui on a mis des amitiés le
petit monde vient le dimanche le samedi
le dimanche en fonction de quand on
organise le retournement on baisse et
tout dit que c'est pas la braise compost
hop on tourne c'est une hélice ça rentre
tout seul donc on le rentre sur une
vingtaine centimètres on ressort donc la
matière qui était en dessous passe au
dessus
et ça permet d'aérer le compostage c'est
un procédé on va dire de dégradation de
des biodéchets donc les plus sûrs les
peaux de bananes marc de café à partir
de 6 mois on obtient du compost donc le
compost c'est un petit peu ce qu'on voit
au pied des armes dans la forêt c'est
l'humus en fait le fruit du travail
collectif est ensuite redistribué aux
habitants et utiliser pour le potager de
la résidence cet engrais naturel servira
à enrichir les plantations en mars 2023
Didier Chambon passera une formation
professionnalisante pour devenir maître
composteur il sera notamment habilité à
gérer des projets de compostage auprès
des collectivités
aujourd'hui il était tourné le nouveau
numéro du Pass du PAF Patrice and
friends dans cette émission Patrice
carmouz revient avec quatre femmes
invitées la députée Marie le pennerie le
palek maire de Chevreuse Florence
Mercadet avocate et mathildeau
spécialiste de communication sur les
grands événements de l'année évidemment
sur la guerre en Ukraine quelle
influence à cette guerre sur le
renforcement de l'Europe réponse de
Marine Le Pen il parle d'une voix en
dehors des questions énergétiques parce
que les enjeux sont extrêmement partagés
mais sur le soutien à l'Ukraine sur la
logique agresseur agressée je crois
qu'elle parle d'une loi unanime et puis
par exemple de l'Allemagne
européenne par la défense
européen
elle revient dans les moments de très
forte tension on l'a connu aussi pendant
le covid assez valeurs fondamentales qui
sont la coopération le travail ensemble
même si on même si on s'échappe le reste
du temps il y a des points de vue qui
sont extrêmement différents même si on
n'aborde pas les questions de la même
manière quand l'Europe unique sous
pression et même c'est difficile quand
l'Europe est mise sous pression elle est
capable de revenir à ses valeurs
essentielles et ce qui fait ce pourquoi
c'est aliments je voudrais juste dire un
mot aussi c'est que inversement il faut
regarder aussi les votes à l'ONU sur la
scène internationale quand il s'agit de
sanctionner la Russie etc il y a
beaucoup de pays qui s'appellent et donc
il faut pas nier le poids du soft power
aussi russe et moi je le vois pour avoir
présidé le groupe d'études de le groupe
d'amitié France Côte d'Ivoire avec la
Côte d'Ivoire enfin dans cette
ère où la France est extrêmement
influente du du Mali du Burkina de la
Côte d'Ivoire du Sénégal etc la montée
en puissance de rue et donc il ne faut
pas le nier et d'une il faut être très
ferme sur les valeurs auxquelles nous
croyons mais de deux je pense que isoler
la Russie refuser d'échanger avec eux
etc c'est aussi pousser tout un tas de
pays qui cherchent finalement une autre
forme de régime que le régime
démocratique auquel on croit et qui se
tourne vers la Russie comme comme un
allié objectif et donc ça c'est à mon
avis pour moi à long terme aussi une
menace qui est assez forte et qu'on ne
peut pas exclure avant de se quitter un
petit point sur la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain pour le jour le plus court de
l'année le matin il y aura quelques
éclaircies sur l'ensemble des Yvelines
on pourra donc profiter un peu du soleil
du côté et des températures comptées 8
degrés Versailles 7 degrés à Rambouillet
8 degrés ou dents et 7 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie l'après-midi la pluie
arrivera sur le département des Yvelines
il faudra donc prévoir un parapluie par
contre niveau température il fera
relativement doux pour un mois de
décembre il fera 10 degrés à Rambouillet
versaillod et 11 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et demain nous fêterons
la saint Thomas et nous serons en hiver
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi le 7 8 revient demain soir
pour une nouvelle émission en attendant
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
sur TV 78
[Musique]